Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work is about changing already existing
images and videos by adding new objects to
them, or editing their physical attributes.
These editable attributes include gravity,
mass, stiffness, or we can even add new physical
forces to the scene.
For instance, we can change the stiffness
of the watches in this Dalí painting and
create an animation from it.
Physically accurate animations from paintings.
How cool is that?
This is approaching science fiction levels
of craziness.
Animating a stationary clothesline by adding
a virtual wind effect to the scene, or bending
a bridge by changing its mass is also a possibility.
The first reaction I had when I've looked
at this work was "are you kidding me? you
can't edit a photograph!".
Especially that I've seen plenty of earlier
works that tried to do something similar but
each time the limitations were just too crippling
for real-world usage.
And the other ultimate question is always
- how much user interaction does this need?
Is this trivial to use, or is it a laborious
process?
What we need to do is roughly highlight the
outline of the object that we'd like to manipulate.
The algorithm uses a previously published
technique to make sure that the outlines are
accurately captured, and then tries to create
a 3D digital model from the selected area.
We need one more step where we align the 3D
model to the image or video input.
Finally, the attribute changes and edits take
place not on the video footage, but on this
3D model through a physics simulation technique.
A truly refreshing combination of old and
new techniques with some killer applications.
Loving it!
The biggest challenge is to make sure that
the geometry and the visual consistency of
the scene is preserved through these changes.
There are plenty of details discussed in the
paper, make sure to have a look at that, a
link to it is available in the video description.
As these 2D photo to 3D model generator algorithms
improve, so will the quality of these editing
techniques in the near future.
Our previous episode was on this topic, make
sure to have a look at that.
Also, if you would like to get more updates
on the newest and coolest works in this rapidly
improving field, make sure to subscribe and
click the bell icon to be notified when new
Two Minute Papers videos come up.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!